la estabilidad política del Líbano corre
peligro
el tiempo sacaba para que el parlamento
elijo un nuevo jefe de estado después de
que por cuarta vez la votación terminará
con un resultado improductivo de los 110
legisladores que asistieron a la sesión
50 votaron en blanco más que a cualquier
otro postulante
los resultados son los siguientes 50
votos en blanco Michelle 39 votos y Sam
califé 10 votos 13 para un nuevo Líbano
dos votos anulados
la próxima sesión tendrá lugar el jueves
a las 11 de la mañana
para quedarse con el cargo los
candidatos necesitan un mínimo de 65
votos
mojawatt quien está más cerca de ese
número no tiene el respaldo del poderoso
partido hezbolá y sus aliados salvo un
cambio rotundo el panorama no es
auspicioso para el Líbano tiene hasta el
viernes para definir una nueva autoridad
o se generará un vacío de poder ese día
el ciclo de michela aún expirará y
deberá dejar el Palacio presidencial el
lunes siguiente
en contrapartida los bloques negocian
para nombrar Un gobierno interino sin
embargo un ejecutivo transitorio no
tiene la facultades para asumir las
funciones de un presidente y tampoco
Parece ser una tarea sencilla desde
junio el Primer Ministro micati no pudo
armar un gabinete de ministros que
conforme a los distintos partidos